joe biden attempted to keep public
opinion focused on a promise kept after
20 years the u.s was finally leaving
afghanistan
i stand squarely behind my decision
after 20 years
i've learned the hard way
that there was never a good time to
withdraw
u.s forces
but neither the president or any
administration official has been able to
address the chaotic manner of that
withdrawal despite biden's proclamation
that the buck stopped with him he lashed
out both of the afghan military and the
afghan political leadership that fled
even saying the u.s had wanted to
evacuate more people earlier but was
stopped by kabul i know there are
concerns about why we did not begin
evacuating
afghans civilians sooner
part of the answer
is some of the afghans did not want to
leave earlier
still hopeful
for their country
and part of it because the afghan
government
and its supporters discouraged us from
organizing the mass exodus to avoid
triggering as they said
a crisis of confidence at the pentagon
officials insisted that they had
role-played every eventuality there
wouldn't be drawn on whether that
included such a swift taliban takeover
or whether such a possibility had been
communicated to the president
plans are not always perfectly
predictive and you
and as is a well-known military maxim
that plans don't often survive first
contact uh and you have to adjust in
real time
the pentagon says it expects the 2500
u.s troops in kabul at the airport to be
supplemented within 24 hours by up to a
thousand more and says that airport
operations have resumed in addition the
us says more than 700 afghans who were
eligible for special immigration visas
had left the country over 48 hours
bringing the total to almost 2 the
president's opponents have been swift to
deliver a withering commentary
honestly this administration looks to me
like it couldn't organize a two-car
funeral
and maybe it's not too late i hope not
for the president to put in enough
troops in and around kabul
to at least get out
all the americans and as many of the
afghans as possible who are our friends
who are interpreters who rely
on whom we were lied all of these years
it is a sad day
for the united states of america however
when pressed mcconnell as with many
others in washington suggested his
favorite option was a permanent military
presence in afghanistan which would be
against the wishes of a majority of
americans the biden administration
appears to be hoping that eventually the
chaos of the last few days will be
forgotten and instead the president will
be seen as the commander-in-chief who
finally brought america's longest war to
an end shia abretancy al jazeera
washington